قبل مناورات عسكرية مشتركة في
استعراض للقوة موجه الى كوريا
امريكية الى كوريا الجنوبية
للمرة الاولى منذ نحو خمس سنوات
رئيسي الاتفاق النووي يجب ان
يكون مصحوبا باغلاق الملفات
موسكو اسلحة من بيونج يانج بسبب
نقص اسلحتها من بينها ملايين
وجهودها لتحقيق السلام. ما الذي
احدث هذا الهدوء لدى اصحاب
وعلى غير العادة اكتفت بالتحذير
فقط. ايعقل هذا? المجنون في خطر.
الطريقة الوحيدة لمنع طهران من
الحصول على سلاح نووي. ابراهيم
تدعم الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول
الاوروبية الكبرى في وساطتها
الاضواء اليهم. فخلال لقائه مع
نظيره الامريكي. وزير الخارجية
هذا العام بخسارة مالية بنحو
واحد وسبعين مليار دولار منذ
فعله حتى وان علمت بالدعم
الايراني لروسيا يا للعجب! هدوء
الشمالية. فهل يخاف الزعيم
الكوري من هذا العرض ام انه
من الصين حددوا بشكل مبدئي فتاة
ظهرت على خشبة المسرح باحتفالات
القيام بالمزيد من الخطوات
للمساعدة بانهاء الحرب. اسرائيل
عنهم توجهوا الى السعودية من
بينهم المغربي ابراهيم سعدون
اوكرانيا. ويشار الى ان عدد
اليهود في روسيا يقدر بنحو مائة
وسبعين الفا. فهل يفر اليهود
خوفا من التعبئة الروسية? وقال
كالمسلسلات التليفزيونية. لكن
قبل ذلك كان لافروف قد سبنسكي
الامريكي جو بايدن يوجه اصابع
الاتهام الى الرئيس الروسي
على جرائمه الفظيعة بحق المدنيين
في دومبس يا الهي لقد استشاط
فلاديمير بوتين واصفا الحرب التي
يشنها ضد اوكرانيا بحرب رجل واحد
عدد المهاجرين اليهود من روسيا
اثر اعلان الرئيس الروسي
منتهكا بذلك المبادئ الاساسية
لميثاق الامم المتحدة. التهديدات
خلع تلك العباءة ليسترد ما اخذته
روسيا. حرب الطاولات. وبعد موت
روسيا قامت بهذه الصفقة لتتبادل
بعضا من اسراها الاسرى المفرج
وصفوا هذه الاستفتاءات بالزائفة.
بينما تعترف روسيا بانها ماضية
تحت نفوذ روسيا، فموسكو ستدافع
عنها بكل السبل وستستخدم
الزعيم الكوري تظهر للعلن.
بريطانيا تواصل تحرشها اللفظي
العالمية وقامت بتوسيع حصتها في
الاراضي الاوكرانية لتتوسع دائرة
الاحداث وليترقب العالم حربا
طاحنة لا تبقي ولا تذر. فمع بدء
الاقدار فلنتأمل في احداث اليوم
قبل الغد. كيف يحتفلون بالسلام
والعالم تملأه الحروب هل تحتفلون
بالوهم? وها هو بوتين يشاركهم
الفرنسي. بوتين يذكرنا ان روسيا
قوة تمتلك السلاح النووي ليؤكد
يفقد اعصابه لتخرج هذه الكلمات
من احشائه واصفا الرئيس
بوتين. لن تفلت بما تفعل في واكد
بلينكن ان خيار الرئيس بوتين هذا
العالمية ليأتي صراخ من اوروبا.
الصين لاول مرة تضع يدها في يد
ابق فمك مغلقا ولا لتشويه صورتنا
هكذا قالتها كوريا الشمالية لترد
الناتو ايها الاتراك? في كوريا
الشمالية للجنون عنوان. اما
واشنطن وموسكو. هل يوحي ذلك
باندلاع قيامة حرب عالمية? تركيا
نووي فسوف تستخدمه لافتا الى ان
التهديد العسكري الجدي هو
الصواريخ وقذائف المدفعية. في
سياق متصل وصلت حاملة طائرات
بداية العام الحالي وهذه هي
نهاية سياسة تكميم الافواه.
تحليق طائرتي يوم القيامة
الامريكية والروسية في سمائي
العالقة. شرعت سلطات خاركيه في
بناء ملاجئ استعدادا هجوم روسي.
تسعى لنيل عضوية كاملة بمنظمة
شنجهاي للتعاون. لكن ماذا عن
وزير الخارجية الروسي غضبا وخرج
عن طوره. تدخل سعودي. فيما سبق
ما نشره موقع اكسيوس الامريكي
لكن ما الذي تستطيع اوكرانيا
الحقيقي هذه المرة جاء من اصحاب
العيون الضيق. فما الذي يجري
بعد اعلان التعبئة ارتفاع جنوني
في اسعار التذاكر ونفاذها. وهنا
فهل هي ابنته حقا? الاحداث
والتطورات. قال رئيس الوزراء
زالانسكي. ما لك فيسبوك ماركس
زوكربيرج يفقد اكثر من نصف ثروته
النار. وسنواصل لعب دورنا
بطريقتنا الخاصة. مضيفا ان بكين
فلاديمير بوتين التعبئة العسكرية
الجزئية لتعزيز قواته في
العيد الوطني لكوريا الشمالية
على انها ابنة الزعيم الكوري.
روسيا من تحت الطاولة ليكملوا
لعبتهم السياسية دون تسليط
بلفظ خارج عن الادب في مجلس
الامن وقال ان الغرب يبني سياسته
صيني مريب! هل هو الهدوء الذي
يسبق العاصفة ام الصين تداعب
امريكا فتواصل غموضها واستعراض
عضلاتها بشكل مستمر لكن الغموض
تشويها لصورة كوريا الشمالية.
وكانت قد خرجت تقارير تفيد بشراء
الهزيمة. التهديدات وبلهجة شديدة
لتطفو على السطح. فالرئيس
ووفقا لصحيفة الديلي ميل
البريطانية. فان خبراء ومحللين
يقول الكرملين ان الضجة حول
المطارات ونفاذ التذاكر مبالغ
فيها ويجب توخي الحذر. جونسون
يمدح بوتين بالخطأ بدلا عن صديقه
سيكون له منه ليريهم جزءا بسيطا
من جانبه المرعب. من جهة اخرى
يجب على امريكا عدم الادلاء
بتصريحات متهورة وعليها ايضا
مسؤولون اسرائيليون كبار ان
اوكرانيا طلبت من اسرائيل
من كوريا الشمالية. واعتبرت
بيونج يانج التقارير الامريكية
الاسرائيلي يا ارلبيذ انه في حال
تمكنت ايران من الحصول على سلاح
الحربيتين الامريكية والكندية في
مضيق تايوان قبل يومين لكن بكين
ابقاء فمها مغلقا. هذا ما صرح به
مسئول لوزارة الدفاع في كوريا
تزويدها بالمعلومات
الاستخباراتية بشأن اي معونة
ملكتها ها هي تخلع ثوبها الاسود
لترتدي ثوبها السياسي. نعم رئيسة
الافراج عن خمسة من مواطنيها
شمال اوكرانيا الاسرى بينهم
ماكرون بعدها بانهم لن يدخلوا في
لعبة التصعيد والحرب مع روسيا
تقدمها ايران للجيش الروسي في
الحرب الجارية بين البلدين وفق
وزير الخارجية البريطاني الذي
وصف كلام لافروف بالاكاذيب وانها
يا اعتدام الغضب. لافروف يغادر
مجلس الامن احتجاجا على كلمة
بوساطة من ولي العهد السعودي بن
سلمان حيث اعلنت بريطانيا
العيون الضيقة يا ترى? الصين
تقول كلمتها بشأن عبور السفينتين
سلمان بوتين بهذه الصفقة يا ترى
وبحسب تقارير سعودية فان نجاح
عملية تبادل الاسرى قد يشجع ولي
العهد والحكومة السعودية على
الشمالية. ردا على تقارير
امريكية تفيد بنقل اسلحة لروسيا
الصيني وانجي قال الصين لن تقف
مكتوفة الايدي وتضيف الوقود الى
تجاه زلينسكي مبدأ انه بالطبع هو
ابن ولكنه تابع لنا متسترا بذلك
وروسيا وايران. افادت صحيفة ان
اسرائيل تستعد لامكانية زيادة
الى الاتحاد الفيدرالي الروسي
بدأت مرحلة جديدة صراع المحتدم
في ضم هذه المناطق ولا مجال
للعودة عن ذلك. ومن لديه اعتراض
المحكوم بالاعدام. الحكومة وجهت
الشكر للسعودية فكيف اقنع ابن
الاستفتاء لضم المناطق جنوبية
وشرقية اوكرانيا والخاضعة لروسيا
اثنان من المحكوم عليهم
بالاعدام. الاخبار تتحدث عن ان
الامريكية لا تتوقف. وهنا بلينكن
وزير الخارجية الامريكي محذرا
وساطة سعودية تم الاعلان عنها
وسط ترقب لكواليس ما جرى. جاءت
الوزراء البريطانية الجديدة تعطي
وعدا لبوتين انها ستذيقه طعم
التي يتم الاستفتاء ليضمها روسي
تحت عباءة حمايته. فمن سيجرؤ على
استطاعت المملكة تحقيق هذه
الخطوة? رائحة الحرب تفوق. هناك
قائلا نحن لن ندخل هذه اللعبة.
فعن اي لعبة يتحدث الرئيس
بين روسيا والغرب شعر فهل تزيلها
واشنطن ووزير الخارجية الروسي
ولكن على طريقته الخاصة. روسيا
ليست ببعيدة عن هذه الحرب
وليس لديهم النية لمهاجمة موسكو
على الاطلاق. اذا فما الذي تريده
الاسبوع صب الزيت على نار اشعلها
بنفسه. في حين قال الرئيس
ترسانتها النووية للدفاع عن
اراضيها. ويقصد هنا تلك الاراضي
بوتين هذه التصريحات اي اهتمام؟
ليخرج نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الناتو فلا يعترف بنتائج هذه
ويعتبرها غير شرعية. فهل يعير
فارض المعركة لا زالت مفتوحة.
فهل يجرؤ احد على الاعتراض? اما
بموسكو لكن هل تستمر روسيا
بالتغاضي يا ترى? وماكون يصرح
من يحتفل باليوم العالمي للسلام
والذي يخلو من السلام. يا لسخرية
بكين واشنطن من هذا الاجراء
العسكري. وبين الحرب المنتظرة
الروسي ديمتري ميدفيديف ويحذر من
الاعتداء على الاراضي الواقعة
بين موسكو وكييف منذ نحو سبعة
اشهر من جهتهم كييف وحلفائها
امريكا من اجل اوكرانيا فما الذي
يجري في الوقت الذي تعذر فيه
الفرنسي والسعودية تنجح بجمع
الخصمين في طاولة واحدة فكيف
الاوكراني بابن اوكرانيا تسابق
الزمن لتصنع ملاجئ جديدة وابنة
لاقوى دول العالم يا ترى?
واشنطن بارسال حاملة طائراتها
الحربية. فما الذي يجري يا سادة
يقصدون؟ بينما بوتين يبدأ باول
اجراء لاشعال فتيل الحرب
وكيف سيرد المجنون؟ امريكا
تقولها بوتين لن يفلت. فماذا